Well,
the violin is,
for me,
it's one of my voices.
Um,
it's one of the voices that express my
thoughts,
my feelings,
my understandings of different things in
different matters.
Um,
it tries to communicate
different messages,
different ideas.
Um,
different discoveries,
um,
different beliefs,
different interpretations.
Um,
many different things.
violence is really for me to voice.
My violin was made in 1734.
It's made by granaries still jaisal.
I'm one of the two.
I'm most notable acres for the
instrument of the violin.
Um,
and I've had it for a little over 10
years now.
Um,
it's Italian,
it's made like a starter as violent or
other ordinary as violence meeting
Cremona in Italy and um,
it's difficult to say,
you know,
what's the violin and what's me because
it's the combination that really makes
it very unique.
Um,
another player playing the exact same
violin,
um,
would sound very differently.
Um,
I might play another instrument.
I'm not the one that I have,
but might be something else and I would
still sound like me also,
but it's really a combination.
And also,
I do think that the violent is a living
being.
Um,
first of all,
it's extremely sensitive to humidity and
to heat temperature changes.
Um,
it's very,
very capricious.
It's very,
I'm temperamental.
Um,
it's,
it gets grouchy.
It's,
you know,
I'm meant to a good mood.
Takes regular maintenance.
That's like going to violin doctor.
Um,
but I actually love this instrument and
it just feels,
it just feels like this is the partner
that I want.
Um,
and I'm very,
very grateful for having access to such
a great instrument.
It is.
It doesn't matter food place on it.
It is a great instrument,
but it's something about this particular
great instrument that I'm just so I'm
attracted to.
And I think it's a lot to do with
chemistry as well.
It's not something you know,
that,
um,
one can say as well,
if you put this element into this
violent,
then this person's going to like it
better is I think just a combination of
known and unknown things that make it
very,
very special.
I consider it a partner.
I don't think of it as an extension of
myself and people like to think that,
um,
you know,
well,
a violin could be like a part of your
body or a part of you.
I think it's a wonderful partner.
Um,
I do give it that little distance that
it's something that lives with that
objective.